ra cái này góp ý các bạn là nhiều hơn
thì
ở gần đây mình có thấy các bạn đang học
à từ dưới Nói chung là kiểu không ngon
ngưỡng faction nữa rồi là mức Suneo có
Tức là sao nghĩa là các bạn ạ Ngoài kiểu
làm những cái cầu theo như mình mình chỉ
đâu thì làm lấy giờ các bạn nó tự chịu
khó tìm hiểu thêm thì cả đời khác tốt
cho cả ở chịu khó tìm hiểu thêm công
nghệ là ta hơi hướng như là nó bị nhược
điểm ký đó là ở các bạn vẫn ở trong
ngỗng dưa leo tức là sau khi
thì nó sẽ có những giai đoạn như thế này
nó ra đoạn đầu tiên là là chẳng biết gì
cả Không ạ chẳng biết gì cả thì mình sẽ
cần cải thiện như nào đó là phải cốt
nhiều hơn đấy tiếp theo là đây là giai
đoạn 1 năm hoặc đoạn 2 sẽ là sẽ là kiểu
khi mà mới mới biết một chút chẳng hạn
thì lại rất ham
kiểu ham công nghệ xong ngồi kiểu ham
cốt các cậu như
đam mê ngày đêm cốt các thứ thứ thấy cốt
là mình chứ gì đó Đang rất vĩ đại cái gì
đó Bởi vì bởi vì từ cái hồi mà chưa biết
gì cả Bây giờ mới cố rồi nên cảm thấy
gặp thỏa mãn thì ông kiểu Ý
a cho dạng nào kéo tao đã rất dài rảnh
rồi như rùa vui thời này thời tôi biết
ta vui như lúc này thì mấy ông lại phải
lúc này lại phải bình tĩnh lại
xây dựng cái đồ lạnh và cốt ít hơn
Anh nghĩ nhiều hơn Cốt
tin tức là sao Nghĩa là đừng có ra đoạn
này thì các bạn biết cốt rồi đúng không
ạ thì các bạn là phải kiểu phải ngồi
nghĩ trước khi cốc cái thở ra ăn này là
thời gian phải cốc nhiều hơn để cho nó
quen
hiểu được cốt chạy đúng không ạ Và nhớ
luật của Pháp đủ kiểu Còn bây giờ khi
các bạn biết rồi các bạn phải phải bình
tĩnh ạ kiểu
cốt mà nghĩ nhiều không ạ Chứ việc mà
tay nhanh hơn não sẽ dậy dẫn đến rất
nhiều thứ ông ạ Đấy Nói chung là mấy ông
phải tính kỹ trước đã giống như hồi
trước tôi không biết tôi kể với ông về
vụ đấy chưa Hồi trước tôi có thằng bạn
đó là
à Nó chơi trò nó còn phải chơi là nó để
đồng hồ đồng hồ bấm giờ ấy ạ Đúng kiểu
là một ngày cho hơn nó rất đam mê công
nghệ đến bây giờ nó vẫn nằm Mẹ nó bây
giờ đây là bí rồi thì một ngày nó chỉ
cốt đúng một tiếng một tiếng thôi
đi tìm mấy ông sẽ tự mắt một tiếng làm
sao mà đi bất kịp được rõ ràng mình có
tầm nửa tiếng thì phải 3 môn tiếng mình
bị mất bây giờ tại sao một tiếng đi bất
kỳ được thì bản chất là nó không Cốt nó
có ghi ra giấy nó ghi ra dài rất nhiều ý
tưởng khi xài rất nhiều trường hợp sau
đó thì nó chỉ dành một tiếng để cắm đầu
vào cốc thôi lúc đấy cốt của nó rất là
ngon đó là xịn cô để lâu chắc thằng đấy
không có một cái bóp vì gan như không có
bất kỳ à đông nhân hồi gian đầu đâu ngờ
nó không có chuyện đấy đang đầu có một
đông bắc đó ngoạn sông ấy vẫn cố kiềm
chế là ông ấy phải ngày hôm sau mới được
18 rồi cốt chứ không phải là cốt quán
thời gian một tiếng đấy thì lúc đấy ông
ấy sẽ nghĩ rất nhiều trường hợp để tránh
việc là ngày hôm sau lãng phí cái một
tiếng kia nên thành ra là chỉ cần như
tiếng nào Một tiếng của ông ấy rất là
Minh Mẫn và rất là chất lượng Bởi vì ông
tính hết Ghi hết là có nhiều giấy cực
ghi hết mọi ý tưởng thì hết mọi trường
hợp mọi thứ có thể xảy ra để ông ấy khi
mà cốc thì là nếu không hiểu cho
cái việc à ghi ra giấy đấy Không cần
phải ghi hàn cốt đã rời đâu nếu không sẽ
ghi kiểu dạng là giống như sinh thoảng
mấy ông thấy rồi ghi cái gọi người ta
gọi là mã ra trước cả kiểu gọi là ghi
các trường hợp các ý tưởng các thứ thì
sẽ ghi các trường hợp ra cho mì phân
tích ở trường hợp này thì sẽ có rủi ro
gì nó sẽ nó sẽ xảy ra những trường hợp
như thế nào ngoạn xấu ở gì tốt là gì Vân
Đấy mình sẽ nghĩ hết trước tất cả những
việc đấy và khi cốt thì mình chỉ cốt
thôi
A
và đây là cái ngưỡng Junior này gỡ phải
ngượng facile này gỡ này ngưỡng nhưng
của bọn ông này rồi đến cái ngưỡng tiếp
theo là khi mà Mấy ông đã bình tĩnh thì
cốt rồi làm bắt đầu lên những tsuneo rồi
đấy thì cần Như là ông sẽ kiểu phải phải
học phải đọc thêm tài liệu chuyên sâu
này
cũng chưa đến mức là phải đến mắt chưa
đến mức vừa phải kiểu học rất nhiều ngôn
ngữ nhé hợp với ngôn ngữ theo thử cho
tôi không đề cập bởi vì nhiều người sẽ
có nhiều kiểu nghĩ khác nhau có người
nghĩ rằng nhà để mà cho làm Master theo
kiểu loa kiểu là kiểu expert tức là kiểu
chuyên gia lập trình thì phải biết ngôn
ngữ có người nghĩ thế có người thì lại
nghĩ là là anh phải cực kì tokichoi theo
kiểu là nắm chắc về rất chắc về Cái lõi
của cái ngôn ngữ đấy cũng như là cậu rất
không phải là nhớ Với các hàm nhớ càng
nhiều hàng thì càng giỏi nhá hỏi thế mà
biết được là ngôn ngữ này yếu là gì mạng
là gì Ví dụ là sự TP hạ nó mạnh ở điểm
nào Tại sao đến giờ vẫn được Đúng đấy
chẳng hạn thế nó yếu ở điểm nào tại sao
bây giờ có nhiều ngôn ngữ khác và thường
ai bảo ngôn ngữ php là ngôn ngữ Đã Chết
đấy Mấy ông mới biết qua lý thuyết là
mày cái đấy Nhưng thực sự là cái ông
hiểu được bản chất là tại sao lại như
thế không đấy Tại sao lại P8 chẳng ạ mới
ra ạ nó thay đổi những cái gì sao tv7
đấy
tư vấn và văn thì nếu mà chưa soạn
chuyên sâu hơn rạch ròi hơn tất cả nhiều
cái và đương nhiên đi kèm những việc đấy
rồi phải có nắm chắc lý thuyết về cả
thuật toán cũng như
các kiểu vân nữa cái đấy nhiều lắm
Nói chung nhà từ Sino ngoặc Suneo
thì phải đọc thêm rất nhiều tài liệu
Sino là cái ngưỡng mà phải làm là Bình
tĩnh rồi đấy cốt nghĩ ra thừa thứ nhưng
mà để đem Master thì sẽ phải đọc thêm
rất nhiều tài liệu chuyên sâu và phải
đứng yên ở đương nhiên phải đi kèm với
với kinh nghiệm thực tế rất nhiều nhiều
chứ không phải mỗi lý thuyết sua lý do
xua người ông giống như kiểu ông Tiến sĩ
Thạc sĩ thì không có nghĩa là ông sẽ gọi
là Master ở trong lợn nhà người trình
này đâu kể cả ông vác ấy bằng tiến sĩ và
nhờ Vân vì nó không là cái gì cả trong
ngày này không thể so sánh kiểu đấy được
phải có kinh nghiệm thực tế phải kinh
nghiệm thực hành nhiều thì nó mới lên
được không ạ Có những người tôi biết
được là cốt đến từ 2.000 đến 3.000 giờ
ngày âm chưa họ đi làm quá là năm 30
tuổi rồi họ vẫn làm được trình viên
nhưng họ chỉ có ở cái ngưỡng vẫn là
ngưỡng dữ liệu này không lên nổi Sino
bởi vì họ không nghĩ nhiều họ cứ cốt họ
cứ cắm đầu cốt đấy họ không nghĩ họ
không để ý họ không đọc thêm tài liệu họ
chỉ cốt thôi cốt đồng những cái mà họ đã
biết mà họ không phát triển họ không
nghĩ rằng ạ Cái đoạn mày nên cần tối ưu
thêm như thế nào mà họ mà họ chỉ cốt để
mà sao mà chạy được là được thế thì
không thể lên được những tsuneo rồi chứ
đừng nói là lên master để Master thì gần
như là nó là một sự ra thần thánh không
ạ rất nhiều người ấy bảo thế yêu kiểu là
Ừ nhưng mà thực tế thì như tôi và phong
cách chỉ là nhiều người sẽ bảo là kiểu
Master thì sẽ đồng nghĩa việc là biết
nhiều ngôn ngữ Cái này thì ra có một
phần đúng bởi ngôn ngữ ngôn ngữ nói
chung thì ở nó khá khá giống nhau và
Master thường là biết qua ngôn ngữ này
thế mạnh là gì ngôn ngữ kia thế mẹ là gì
Giống như là các anh mà tôi từng biết
thì mình ấy kiểu gần như là ví dụ là sự
là hồi đấy Giống như cái câu chuyện mà
tôi thường kể mấy ông là hồi mà tôi làm
ở công ty công ty đầu tiên đưa làm thì
làm toàn bộ bằng pp
ở cây cảnh sát tới toàn bộ bằng pp là ạ
thì cái Trang đấy mất công một lần nó
tải bởi vì nó thống kê các thứ nó bất
tận hơn mười giây liền để tải xong thì
lúc đấy anh ấy nghĩ là phải cần một
Facebook dress with để mà chạy xử lý
băng bất đồng bộ cả nào được tải xong
trước nhìn thấy ở trước để người dùng đỡ
phải đợi là kiểu nó phải thoát được đồng
loạt hết thì nó mới bị ra thì lúc đấy
người dùng nhìn thì trang trắng tinh 10
giây nóng thì ra đến chắc là người dùng
bỏ hết về người dùng sẽ nghĩa là đầu
tiên là suy nghĩ mạng mà có vấn đề nó sẽ
thử mở google.com nên nhìn lại mình xem
mà thực sự do mạng hay do cha nhóm mấy
ông còn đây rồi rõ ràng làm thấy mạng nó
ngon có mỗi trang của mấy ông tầm 10
giây xong thì bị lên nó thừa người dùng
cũng đợi Giận 10 giây đâu thì người dùng
thấy làm 5 giây thời trang tinh tế người
ta Thoát hết rồi đấy thì
Ừ thì kệ anh mà biết đấy Anh đấy Lúc đầu
chỉ biết tiếp theo nhé nó cả ra sức cơ
bản thôi nhưng mà anh ấy chỉ cần mất vài
ngày để đọc tài liệu là anh ấy có thể
làm Facebook gia speaking for Thì đấy là
cái ngưỡng của Master tớ cảm lỡ Master
làm gì là khi mà quá rảnh về lập trình
rồi cũng như cấu trúc hay hiểu rõ bản
chất của nó rồi thì chỉ cần đọc cú pháp
của cái ngôn ngữ khác khác là điểm gì
cũng như là nó có thêm cái gì mới rồi
nhảy sang được luôn không cần phải cậu
không cần phải Kiểu Học lại từ đầu không
khái niệm là nhảy sang ngôn ngữ khác bạn
từ đầu đó Khi mà lên Bình Nhưỡng Sino
Masters này sang ngôn ngữ khác cũng rất
là dễ Hãy dùng từ dễ Ừ đấy thì trông Hà
gần như là bây giờ tôi đã khuyên mấy ông
đó là
ạ Bây giờ chúng ta không nên ham ngôn
ngữ mà nên tập trung vào một cái cốt lõi
1 cái bản chất đã phẩm chứa mấy ông cốc
pp thuần cũng được Nhưng mà thực sự mình
nhảy sang mô hình hoặc ở một vương quốc
thì khá tốt từ như tôi đang dậy thì để
mà về mà kiểu khi mà bây giờ chẳng ai
làm phân cả ai cũng làm thêm cái mô hình
và một cái Phương Quốc để luôn bởi vì
vương quốc Nó rất tiện
và Vân nó kiểu ngoài tiện tiện nó
Facebook không khiến nó cốt mà ông chạy
nhanh hơn nhé Hôm trước có bạn bảo tôi
Tại sao em dùng pp thuần chạy nhanh thế
tôi sang Facebook razul Tưởng ngon thế
nào rồi chạy còn chậm hơn thì rõ ràng
Facebook nó sẽ chạy sẽ chạy qua rất
nhiều cái cậu hàng chạy qua rất nhiều
các thứ trước khi nó nhảy sang người
chính thức để hiển thị thì thì rõ rõ
ràng là Facebook nó sẽ chạy chậm hơn so
với thuần nhưng nó sẽ mạnh hơn được việc
tối ưu
từ hạt dùng thì tối yêu không đủ nóng
lạnh hơn nữa tinh chỉnh nó ngồi xuống
thứ tinh chơi tôi đang dùng hết toàn bộ
từ tiếng Việt có nếu mà tiếng Anh của nó
sẽ là là kiểu Compact này cấu hình này
cậu Custom Ai là tinh chỉnh hoặc person
à personal ID thì ra không đúng không
phải cá nhân hóa đây nhưng nói chung là
nó có thể mở rộng và nâng cấp nữa bảo
trì các hơn nó sẽ xịn hơn spyphone bất
kỳ ngôn ngữ nào Thế cứ có Facebook thì
kiểu gì nó sẽ mạnh hơn theo kiểu là nó
dễ cho lập trình viên chứ không phải là
chứ không phải là khiến nó nó chạy nhanh
hơn đâu Nếu phải phân biệt điều đấy tiếp
theo
có
rất nhiều bạn đang là mức Junio và Ừ
phải thêm một cái nữa Ở đây đó là
biết cách trả tài liệu
và biết đọc lỗi
thức ra sao nghĩa là
chào các bạn Hiện tại vẫn còn đang thứ
nhất là lỗi hiển thị lên không biết
không biết được đấy là lỗi gì em một cái
sai Các bạn phải làm quen được là là lỗi
hiển thị lên thì mình phải biết được là
nó sai ở đâu
ở gần như là phải biết được điều đấy đã
mình sẽ trả lời nhé à Thi Nếu không phải
biết được rõ bản chất là nó sai ở đâu đã
có cách kể mà Mấy ông thường hay thấy
đôi khi tôi không biết sai ở đâu tôi sẽ
thương ấy để d các tiểu sử để tôi chị
mấy ông ấy người ta hàng Peso mày còn
ngon hơn hàng vét cốt ở điểm này nó có
cái hàm chạy van này nó có thể chạy cái
unit test để không ngoài uống nước em à
còn chạy cái kiểu ví dụ là mấy ông thấy
có cái bộ đồ này không ạ sự tôi màu đỏ 1
bạt đây này
toàn thể chạy từng bước từng bước đến dữ
liệu này và in nhận nó ra cái gì đấy Nó
thể chạy được cả vòng lặp đã từ thứ chị
lắm Khi nào tôi sẽ chạy thử cho bé uống
Sao cái lúc đấy mấy ông sẽ biết được là
cải cách đi bức là cách để biết được nó
chạy đến dòng nào đến dòng nào rồi em ạ
Đấy sau đó thì nó bỏ qua dòng nào có
thời thứ thì mình sẽ mới biết được có
vấn đề Nó nằm nó chết ở cái đoạn nào đấy
một cái ví dụ chẳng
khi đôi khi béo phải xóa cốt đi xóa kodi
để mà để mà biết được trả xử thế là sự
thế mà vẫn nói chung và cách cách đi Bắc
của mấy ông có thể là còn hạn chế thì
mới ông nhưng mấy ông phải biết đọc phục
lỗi Tại sao Bởi vì bởi vì ngoài biết đọc
được lỗi thì
mày Ông còn phải còn từ đấy để mà biết
hỏi rất nhiều bạn inbox cho mình mình cứ
phải ngồi hỏi kỹ hơn phải hỏi kỹ hơn Khá
là mệt cá nhân mình còn thấy mệt anh
không Tôi không biết được là người mà
kiểu giúp các bạn mà kiểu các bạn chắc
chắn các bạn không bỏ tiền họ khi mà nhờ
rồi đúng không ạ Cái cục là cái ra không
người ta sẽ nghĩ là người ta quá nhiều
việc để đang có rất nhiều bất rất nhiều
vấn đề ạ người ta không Thời gian hỏi
bạn Hoàng chuyện ngàn mà tao thấy trả
lời bạn xong cũng không giúp được gì thứ
nhất là không Dù gì người ta thứ hai là
ngợ vì họ nghĩa là bạn trả lời được bạn
một thì bạn có thể vì sao lại hỏi tiếp
những người ta đôi khi sẽ trốn tránh vân
vân mấy ông biết được mà có thể có rất
nhiều lý do để họ không trả lời trong
đấy ông đặc biệt là khi mà không đi làm
rồi ông sẽ rất là ngại hỏi đúng ạ thì rõ
ở lại làm phiền người khác đúng ạ Thế
bây giờ ông Ok ông có thể ngại nhưng mà
tôi không khuyên ông là không nên hỏi
đúng không ạ Thế rốt cuộc cản họ thì nên
hỏi như nào Nhớ rồi ông phải biết đọc
lỗi đã đúng ạ để mà ông biết được là
mình sẽ hỏi cái gì bạn có rất nhiều bạn
inbox cho tôi mà anh ơi em làm in rớt
không được ơi thằng gửi cho tôi cái màn
hình Lỗi của mấy ông đấy cũng chẳng gửi
tôi đoạn cốt của ông ấy chỉ nói Vu vơ
câu là anh ơi em làm như anh ấy không
làm được tôi cũng chẳng biết rồi Rốt
cuộc gọi bị lỗi gì đấy chẳng hạn thế nó
khá là ức chế khi mà phải hỏi thêm vài
câu để ông đấy cuối cùng mình gửi cho
hết một loại thấy rằng Ăn thế có người
còn còn tôi phải hỏi đến ba một lần tôi
không hiểu được lỗi ông ấy là gì tôi
đành phải kiu teamview xanh Để mà giải
quyết Bởi vì thực sự thì ông ấy giải
thích rất là mơ hổ và nói rất kiểu ở
thì nó mô tả nó không khó hiểu
Ừ ừ thì đồng ý là mình ở Dân công nghệ
như là thực ra mình để mình nói văn vở
hay nói khó hiểu nó dễ hiểu thì không
phải làm được không ạ nhưng ông phải
biết cách hỏi ông ạ thì tôi đã từng nói
mấy ông về cách hỏi thứ nhất một là đầu
tiên thì
ờ ờ
một là
Ý là nếu mà hiện gửi được cái nội dung
lỗi luôn thì càng tốt đó nội dung lỗi
đúng ạ Nhớ là sử khó thì chị lỗi gì đó
thứ hai là
ở Tà
sự thực là cái đầu tiên thì phải là như
nào nhỉ muốn
Anh muốn làm gì ạ Ông phải nói rõ à Ví
dụ Ông đang làm cái gì sao tự nghiên gặp
Cái lỗi này ông Nam muốn làm cái bóp
không muốn làm cái Insert update ý đó
Đấy nội dung lỗi nếu có Chẳng hạn bây
giờ sư giả sử đơn giản tháng 9 thì đã
lỗi gì nhưng mà nó không nó không làm
được cái thứ uống muốn Insert vào không
hiểu thì lỗi nhưng nhưng mà nhưng mà
không sẽ được không ạ Đấy tiếp theo là
ông đã khử cách nào nếu có đã thử cách
nào
ạ trà sữa Ông cứ nói ý tưởng của ông là
cốt của em đã thử đoạn này không được
đoạn lại không được đấy để cho người ta
nắm rõ đừng có nói là em thử một cách
không được Em thử một cái chị Google
không được không có một cái giải quyết
nào được ghi hết bước một đã trao Google
chưa ra thì hướng nhân gần như là nếu
ông tra Google rồi thì ông hỏi gì đúng
không Tôi đang Tôi đang chỉ chỉ trong
mấy ông về những cái à là
Đó là cách hỏi thôi còn cần như là cái
cách xử lý gồm mấy ông thì nếu phải lựa
đó là mấy ông Nếu đương nhiên nếu phải
tra trước giống như là đã thử những cách
nào trước mà vân chứ không phải là ông
ông bị ỷ lại là theo kiểu là cứ gặp bất
kỳ cái gì sếp vừa ra việc của ông việc
đầu tiên không đi hỏi người khác thế
Không được họ cảm nghĩ cho gã thì cái
đấy là cái đấy là người mấy ông phải tự
chủ động thôi ông ạ nhưng mà ý tôi nội
dung câu hỏi của ông sẽ là như thế này
Đấy là đã thử cách nào nên trình bày một
cách rất là cụ thể chi tiết ra chứ không
nên là kiểu dạng mà là cực chúng chung
em đã thử cháo gồm nhưng không được đấy
Ừ
cái kiểu như thế hoặc cả kiểu em đã thử
cách của anh ấy không được
khi nghe câu nói nó thực sự là kiểu sạc
Như Tôi không biết trả lời có lời như
nào em đã thử cách của anh nhưng không
được
Ừ nó vừa vừa bảo lại đó vừa có thể bảo
là kiểu nó hơi bị Hơi bị của dạng giống
như bảo tôi là cách đối sai nhưng vẫn
hỏi tôi kết hợp được Tôi chẳng biết là
ông ấy có có chuẩn kiểu làm theo đúng
cách của tôi không thế chẳng hạn thế sự
đấy Kiểu này hơi bị khó chịu ông đi này
tiếp theo là là giang sử là ông còn có ý
tưởng nữa là em muốn thuộc cái này nhưng
không biết làm thế nào Chắc lại là muốn
thử
cách này nhưng không biết làm thế nào là
sự thấy nghĩa có ý tưởng thôi Nhưng mà
cái này tùy nhá Cái này cái này thì
tuyển kiểu dạng là cái dù là Em xem trên
mạng thì thấy nó làm cái cầu như thế này
đâu ạ nhưng mà em vẫn chưa biết làm cái
đoạn đấy như thế nào nhanh thì chỉ em
thì không Hoặc em cho anh Ah anh cho em
từ khoán không nên hỏi như thế ở Đại Đế
các câu hỏi của ông có đức nghĩa là vẫn
phải trả tại tra phải thử trước đã chứ
phải khi ông cọp vấn đề gái là ông bỏ
cuộc rồi ông đi nhờ người khác không ạ
Cái Thế thì ông chuyển lương cho tôi
nhiều người sẽ nói thế còn tôi tôi không
quan trọng về tiền bạc thì tội nhưng mà
tội sẽ khó chịu khi mà khi mà thấy mấy
ông Cẩu
Ừ tôi không hỏi dùng tự ý lại ở đây như
tối đa nói kiểu nó sẽ hơi bị nản khi mày
ông lười suy nghĩ một cái vấn đề gì đó
nhưng nhưng cũng phải biết đó là nếu
phải biết khi nào
a khái niệm Nếu phải biết thêm cái khái
niệm này nhé nó khi nào mới ông đi bỏ
của dùng từ bỏ cuộc
anh biết nếu ông biết khái niệm về nhiều
cái gọi bên trước học à kiểu dạng này
biết tiền mà biết được à
ai biết được giới hạn của bản thân
thế giới hạn của bản thân tức là kiểu
Mình chỉ làm được đến thế này thôi nạn
thế hoặc à mình mò xong rồi nó tài liệu
nó chỉ có cung cấp thế này thôi Không
làm được thì mình phải học cách buông bỏ
mình phải biết cách kiểu một là tìm được
người để hỏi không tìm được thì thôi bỏ
con nhờ không thể làm được cái này Các ạ
hoa cả đến giờ chưa nghĩ là phải tạm bỏ
nó xong bên và Vân lúc sau có thể có thể
nghĩ sao hoặc à hoặc là làm cái khác đấy
tượng thế rất nhiều người tôi biết đó là
không hỏi ai tự chủ động làm nhưng không
làm được 23 tuần chỉ một tháng rồi cũng
chính vì mỗi những kẻ như thế khiến họ
chán rồi là ngày này bỏ luôn này
nghĩa chỉ gặp một cái vấn đề rồi không
giải quyết được vấn đề rồi họ bỏ luôn
này có nhá không phải không đâu nên là
cho nên nào thực sự thì
tôi nghĩ là mấy ông cậu phải học cách
gọi là bỏ cuộc đúng lúc này dùng từ bỏ
cô đúng lúc bỏ cuộc nó không gì sai cả
khi mà mình thấy đến kính ngưỡng giới
hạn của mình thì mình sẽ phải
thì mình sẽ phải đâu như là mình sẽ phải
đầu tiên được thư giãn đỡ nhiều người
không biết cách thư giãn nhiều người gặp
vấn đề song cứ phải ngày đêm ngồi cố
giải quyết vấn đề đấy thay vì như thế
thì Méo phải cứ giãn trước đã mày không
phải cái thoải mái đã thì béo mình nghĩ
thông suốt được mới làm được ai Nếu tao
khuyên mày Ông nghĩ thế
còn online thì à à
em trả lời mấy ông kia ờ
Ừ anh có buổi nó giới thiệu đa cơ Với
lại đi mình không dùng Doctor Mình không
biết giới thiệu các bạn kiểu gì
cho là những cái gì mình không chuyên
thì mình xin phép vào không khó chưa sẻ
được
khi Maria xài baggy baggy nation's nó
gọi đến hàm cao dữ liệu lớn thì nó sẽ
dẫn đến bị lâu Đúng không Đúng rồi thực
tế là như thế thực tế thực tế thì nó nửa
Đúng rồi Xay để mình giải thích tại sao
nó đúng là tại sao nó sai nhất là như
bạn ấy bảo là đây cái cái nết không ạ
trang đúng trước nó sẽ chạy chạy ngay
phần tra đúng không Thì nó có khái niệm
simple với inet rất là cả em
cái simple baignade thì mình thường hay
không Mình chưa chỉ các bạn và thường
lại mình Bây giờ mình thường nay ít dùng
đúng không ạ Người Ông Thưởng này thấy
Guinness như thế này gọi bikini cả ngày
thôi Thì cái này nó nó sẽ thực sự thì
cái này chạy nó đúng là chạy thêm một
câu cao sao nữa để mà để mà hiển thị
dạng đề mà biết được là có bao nhiêu
trang để bị Số trang được ạ Cái này thì
anh không chạy lâu cái này tôi có chạy
vẫn rất nhanh về thực tế đó à cái cao
sao Nếu mà không có thêm một câu que gì
cả không có thêm câu điều kiện gì cả thì
nó chạy rất là nhanh bởi vì nó sẽ lấy
trực tiếp ở trong trong bảng trong bảng
của mình vẫn có lưu một cột đếm số bàn
ghi thường tôi nhớ không lầm là hình như
là
nói chung và gần như là cao sao nó sẽ
luôn Chạy nhanh kể cả cho dù ông bảo ông
có bao nhiêu triệu Bạn ghi cao sao vẫn
luôn Chạy nhanh được chứ trừ khi ông
thêm những cái que điều kiện thì đúng là
nó chạy lâu thật đấy thì giả sử khi nó
chạy lâu thì đúng giống như là bạn đạt
kia bạo thì mình sẽ phải chơi một là
simple Paris để nó chỉ cần kiểm tra xem
là có thêm có trang trước trong sau
không thì dán này nó sẽ nó chạy nhanh
cái này thì nó đương nhiên là như cái nó
không phải là cái không phải cái đầy đủ
này nó sẽ có những điểm nó rồi nó là Ừ
cái này tức là sao cái này sẽ
Ừ cái này nó sẽ không đếm toàn bộ có bao
nhiêu trang để ông ạ Nó sẽ chạy nhanh
hơn thì thôi Đây nó có giải thích đây
này
ở đây Bạn không cần quan tâm việc à
trang của bạn có tổng cộng bao nhiêu
trang thì nó thì nó sẽ khá nhé tiếp theo
bạn kia có bảo thì nó là mình có thể
dùng Q show con trỏ Con chó này tức là
sao nó khái niệm rất là hay theo kiểu là
là nó sẽ nó sẽ cậu nó sẽ gần giống gần
giống với cái simple bikini này tôi nhớ
Hình như thế
anh ở đây nó sẽ có khái niệm con chó
ghét với offset cái này rất hay này đây
với với offset bình thường thì ông già
sử ở ở trang 1 của ông nhá ở trang ở
trang thứ hai đi sang thứ hai ông sẽ bỏ
qua 15 Này ông lấy 15 tiếp này như này
thì đối với thằng equus nó có bị nhược
điểm đó là là nó vẫn duyệt qua 15 thằng
này rồi nó mới lấy 15 phần tiếp theo và
giả sử là offset của ông làm 10.000 Ngạn
ra sữa ông nến trang rất là lớn lên
offset 10.000 thì nó vẫn duyệt 30.000
rồi nó mấy 15 thẳng tiếp theo khiến cho
càng offset càng nhiều thì cái loát cái
câu fa này cả nặng Nếu không hiểu cho
nếu đơn giản là chỉ có Limit 15 thôi mà
không gõ xét không phân trang không nhảy
sang trang mới trong thứ hai thì nó rất
nhanh còn càng nhảy càng trang người sau
và nó sẽ phải vượt qua anh vượt qua bao
nhiêu thì bao nhiêu mấy ông hình dung
kiểu dạng như này này
gì hết này là sửa tên là Long này
Ừ lo mày
anh sữa là 20 tuổi em ạ ạ Tiến Anh này
năm tuổi này trở lại rồi tên là văn này
xong rồi 21 tuổi ra xử người sử tôi có
que điều kiện là hết lớn hơn 18 em ạ
xong rồi Tôi chỉ có Lipit một thôi thì
cái bạn long đầu tiên này thỏa mãn rồi
không ạ thì trả về luôn kết quả Ok có
một bạn Long thì mi một ok nhưng nếu là
sử ông làm phân trang ông nhảy sẵn sàng
thứ hai ông vẫn là lý một nhờ ông già
sớm giờ sáng chàng thứ hai tất cả ông sẽ
bỏ qua thằng đầu lấy thằng thứ hai em ạ
Chị sẽ ông sẽ xét một ngày Đúng không
Đúng trước thì gần như là ông duyệt qua
thằng Long Ok như ông ngoại phải duyệt
tiếp của vì nó học Z1 bỏ qua bạn năm đầu
thì ông kiểm tra thằng thứ hai lần thứ
hai không trả mãi ok rồi Ông giờ thần
thứ ba phần thứ ba thỏa mãn thì ông mới
trả về không ạ thì ông vừa thấy là mình
đã phải vượt qua 3 bản ghi bởi vì thêm
màu xét nó vẫn sẽ bỏ qua vòng 1 để diệt
nhiễm hàng dưới cho để thỏa mãn kìa
remake một này nghĩa thỏa mãn offset
xong rồi mới bắt đầu mới kiểm cho thỏa
mãn Limit đấy Xong rồi nó mới lấy thì
thành ra là offset bây giờ giả sử ông
offset thử 10.000 20 triệu một triệu bản
ghi ra sửa ống nhảy sang trang cuối rồi
ạ Đây nhảy offset thật một triệu bạn ghi
thì gần như là
Ừ ông chết là tao bảo ông ạ Ông cần như
ông già hết cả cái bàn luôn gì ạ
Cái Limit này nó sẽ khiến nó nhẹ hơn
nhưng không offset như thế này thì nói
nó sẽ khiến nó vẫn nặng thôi ông ạ
Vì thế nên là thế nên là có cái bài toán
con trỏ này phải toán rất hay này nó là
gần như là là con chó này nó sẽ kiểu nó
sẽ dựa treo cái cột nào đó thường mà cột
ID bàn thường đối với Lara thì nên có
một cột và cột thoái hóa chính tự động
tăng và nay là còn ID ai và mình sẽ dựa
theo con chó này tức là sao Nghĩa à
Nghĩa là
nghĩa là nó sẽ làm thiệp kiểu là
anh ở đây à ở đây giả sử vẫn ếch bằng
lớn 18 không ạ cho ngồi vẫn là lý một
vẫn như bình thường xong rồi Ở đây sẽ
thêm một cột cột ID nữa tự động tam123
đúng ạ Ấy gia sư tử là trang đầu của tôi
đương nhiên trả lời bạn long mới có ai
đi ra một đúng ạ đúng chứ Sau đó thì khi
mà bấm vào trang hay thì rõ ràng mà vừa
nãy là offset đúng nhưng không Bây giờ
mình sẽ là thứ nhất mình vẫn còn order
bye ID như này chẳng hạn và tiếp theo
cho mình mình sẽ gần như là mình que
thêm một cái điều kiện nữa đó là điều
kiện là
anh em rồi
Apple ID
em lại nói bột Nhưng ai đó gần như là
với cái bài toán Con chó này nếu không
sẽ thấy đó nhảy sang thứ hai nó sẽ gần
như là nó không có thêm offset thì cả mà
nó sẽ dựa theo đúng cái cột tự động tăng
của mình và lấy cô tự động tăng đấy lớn
hơn vì con số tự động tăng đấy ví dụ vừa
rồi Trang 1 của mình thì nó trả về bạn
lo rồi thì trang hay nó sáng không trả
lời bạn long mà trả về cả bạn có ai đi
lớn hơn bạn Long tất cả anh lớn một đấy
thì đương nhiên à nó sẽ duyệt bắt đầu
thứ hai luôn và đưa nha bạn không thỏa
mãn và tiếp theo bạn ba bạn thỏa mãn sẽ
trả về bạn Vân ngoài đi là ba đúng chưa
xong rồi Nếu giả sử tôi ngời sáng trang
thứ trang thứ Ba chẳng hạn thì sẽ gần
như là sẽ có ai đi lớn hơn 3 và đưa nghe
không có trả về bạn nào đây rồi giờ sự
thế thì bài toán con trọ nó sẽ làm như
thế nó sẽ kiểu dựa theo chim cánh cụt tự
động tăng này và hãy nên nhớ Bởi vì cột
tự động tăng này nó là khóa chính nó to
yankee nên nó có được đánh đi chị đánh
intek prestos tức à tất cả nó sẽ rất là
nhanh so với Index bình thường không ạ
Nên là và Inax đấy Hạnh in this class
trinx đã tự đã được sắp xếp rồi nên hàng
ra là thầy truy vấn này rất là nhanh
được chưa ạ
em có cũng Q show này vẫn áp dụng được
trong trường hợp khác như nào đấy Thì
ông nên đọc kỹ hơn về cái bài toàn cô
show này Đấy nó thứ nhất là nó lên dựa
Tôi nhớ không lầm là nên dựa theo cái
cột gì gì đó xem
Ừ cái này hộp cho việc và bài toán kiểu
bấm vào để mà kẹo a thường bấm là để chị
thêm này hoặc kéo xuống này hiển thị
thêm mà nó không hợp bài toàn thân Trang
em không nhảy sang xe khác kiểu bệnh hệ
và cái này nó rất là xịn ở điểm ở điểm
đó là
anh ở đây vừa rồi nó có một cái tình
huống này xảy ra
Ừ cái tình huống mà bài toán con trỏ này
thì nói xử lý được Còn bài toán Nếu mà
phân trang vừa rồi của bạn Nó có thể lỗi
nó là như thế này nó như thế này nhá ạ
Bây giờ giả sử giả sử như sự vẫn là x
lớn hơn 18 ngoạn Sau đó mình Lưu Mỹ 10 ạ
ra xử như thế ngay ngay trang một thì
chả thấy bạn Long area 1 đúng trước xong
rồi tự xong rồi tự nhiên mà thôi bỏ Có
ai đi nó quay đi là sợ không có ai đi
nhá
Em ở đó đi này Ai chặn đầu tiên ở sở với
bạn lo lớn nhất đúng không Nhưng mà tự
nhiên tôi mới Insert thêm một bạn nữa là
sử in sẽ bạn nữa
tôi đứng như là cái trường hợp đấy nó
không xảy ra ở đây nhờ tôi đang ví dụ
thế là sử là mình đang sắp xếp kiểu kiểu
gì đó mà tự nhiên tôi Asus được cái bạn
trên là bạn Long này Đấy giờ xử thế
nhưng sợ bạn vẫn nhà bạn này tuổi vẫn là
tuổi 20 đi đây thì thì khi tải lại trang
ấy
sau khi tải lại trang là vẫn là Trang
một tự nhiên Hiển thị các bạn Tuấn không
phải bạn Long nữa đúng không ạ Và cũng
là như thế cũng là như thế ví dụ Giả sử
là bây giờ trang 1 của tôi đang là Long
đối ngoại song với tự nhiên 11 bên admin
vừa thêm bạn Tuấn mà thành ra khi mà tôi
nhảy sang trang Thứ Hai tôi tự nhiên học
sat là một công ạ tôi tự nhiên vẫn nhìn
thấy bạn Năm đấy rõ ràng tôi vừa thấy
Trang bột lại hiển thị bạn lo rồi sôi
tôi bấm sang trang 2 vẫn hiển thị Hạ
Long Bởi vì rõ là và bạn admin mà vừa
mới thêm bạn Tuấn nên mạo Tuấn lại biến
hình ở trong một con bạn Long thì mới
biến thành trang hay thành ra là nó cái
bài toán phân trang này thỉnh thoảng nó
sẽ xe những cái tình huống như thế này
nghĩa là người dùng khi sang trang vẫn
nhìn thấy cái dữ liệu người ta vừa mới
nhìn ở trong 1 cho và ở trong một thì
lại bị thay đổi dữ liệu rồi đấy đứng
nghĩa là cái này thì đối với người dân
công nghệ mình thịt anh hiểu được à Vừa
có thay đổi dữ liệu như người dùng có
hiểu đâu Đúng là người dùng người khi bị
ngu một tí là người ta sẽ không hiểu mày
thấy Trang hay Chồng chả khác gì trong
một cái đấy thành ra là người dùng sẽ
khó hiểu đoạn đây không ạ Còn nếu là bài
toán Con chó này chị nó sẽ gần như không
xảy ra trường hợp đấy bởi vì mình dựa
theo cột ID rồi đó ông ạ Mình sẽ gần như
là mình sẽ luôn were lớn hơn với cái đi
như thế này thì nó gần như nó sẽ không
xảy ra trường hợp đấy ông ạ
cho ví dụ ở Lúc đầu là lúc đầu ra sự ID
của bạn đấy đang nói ví dụ của đại đi
vào đây tự động tăng thì ra nó không có
xảy ra kiếm Dược à Đã bạn Tuấn thì đã
bạn Long thì sẽ chỉ nhảy xong dụ Giả sử
Long là ai đi hay khi mà nhảy sang ID
Lớn Hơn Hai sẽ chỉ người sang bạn anh họ
bạn Vân chứ không có kiểu nhảy có lại
bạn Tuấn đúng ạ Nếu anh để sang trang 2
trong 3 đúng mạ đấy Cái bàn toàn con thỏ
này nó dụng được ưu thế tôi nhớ là cái
này à
đã có nhiều Chính xác là nó là gì nhỉ Nó
phải dựa theo Một Cột nào đó không phải
cô tự động tăng thì cũng phải một cột nó
đó à
cho mình xem nha
những kiểu gì phải thế
anh còn không thì à
xe máy tự động tạo ra một cái con sau đó
sao
order theo Cột nào đó thì mới được mà
Ừ thì mới mới mới mới dùng được thế Cái
con trọ này
chỉ nó qua thôi à
chục dữ liệu như máp đồ không
Ừ đấy về mấy cái có chút dữ liệu được cả
là tôi không rành lắm đâu không phải
nhắm vào TP nào ít hơn thì vậy
anh sẽ nói qua về các bạn về cái vụ à
Ừ ừ thử cài bài toán nó vẫn họ order
vide Nhưng mà đấy là trong trường hợp mà
ông không dùng UAV giống như đang công
ty tôi thôi
anh còn công ty tôi thì bây giờ đang
dùng UV đi và bảo khi bán dữ liệu nhiều
như thế thì đúng là mình người sang cho
tôi bây khác chưa về em của em mẹ của em
nữa thì tao mấy khác giống như ở tôi
đang dùng thì atshop thì nó vừa hỗ trợ
rất nhanh vừa làm kiểu
vừa xuất Nhanh nhá vừa phân trang khá
tốt và nó hỗ trợ về cái việc bài toán
con thỏ vừa rồi đã order không cần phải
dựa theo Cột nào cả Vẫn kiểu dạng này nó
sẽ tự sinh ra một cái một cái gần nhờ
một cái quả như thế nào để tránh các
trường hợp Vừa rồi tôi bảo là kiểu rộng
mà xanh mình mình đang mình đang ở trang
thứ nhất hiển thị bạn này người chọn
tranh 2 vẫn thì các bạn này thì không
phải như thế nó sẽ khái niệm mà nó cách
nó cách lại cái cái à Toàn bộ toàn bộ
cái phân Trang Đấy Trong một khoảng thời
gian nghĩa là người dùng đang ở trong
bột thì đi em 10 bàn ghi khi bấm sang
trang 2 kiểu gì cũng sẽ hiển thị 10 bạn
ý tiếp số trang bột đái không nói chuyện
là kiểu nó Lost lại để mà lấy lấy thêm
thông tin là là gần đây mới thêm bạn nào
để mà trang 2000 thị khác đâu thì thì
cái cách đấy sẽ cách thuộc khái niệm mà
là schoo của chồng mà yêu thích xấu thì
nó sẽ cách tầm 1 phút rồi chẳng hạn
nghĩa là lúc đầu ông sẽ chỉ lúc đầu còn
100 bạn nhiều ạ Ông sẽ có 10 trang và và
trang 1 trang 2 nó sẽ đúng kiểu là mười
bản ghi mà đi tiếp theo cái gì trong
vòng 1 phút sau đó thì sau hết một phút
thì gần Liên nó mới cập nhật lại dữ liệu
1 phát nữa để xem mà thực sự là bây giờ
đang có bao nhiêu ghi nó sẽ phát hành
Ban Nha Trang sau và trong một hiển thị
cho hai thì chị gì sau hãy cân như thế
ông hiểu được hiểu thôi Bây giờ tôi sẽ
hướng dẫn mời ông đến mua cái vụ import
sinh viên hôm trước hôm trước tôi còn
nói quay ạ rồi Tiếp theo thì có nhóm Hôm
trước tôi yêu cầu vào nhóm Hôm nay phải
chữ ạ nhóm 8 thì à
a58 đâu
không Không có nhất thiết phải mỗi nhầm
đấy vào nhóm nào yêu cầu hôm hôm hôm
trước kiểu muốn muốn hôm nay tôi sẽ demo
tôi chấm quạ mà chấm gần như tối chữa
qua nhóm đấy để cho cả nhóm đấy quá à
các nhóm khác khám khảo luôn thì có gì
cơ nhằm nhắn tin nhá Nó không phải nhắn
tin mà bình luận ngay ở đây thì tí Mình
sẽ thử gọi Google mít rồi mình sẽ thử
chấm
nào rồi rồi tôi sẽ chữa do các bạn thế
là tất cả cùng tham khảo nó ngoại
máy tính các thứ thứ mic mông có thứ ổn
lại nhé
ạ
Bây giờ tôi sẽ thử
em inbox gửi inbox sinh viên giống như
tôi bảo bây giờ giả sự là vợ ông làm cái
phần mềm cho phần mềm cho nhà chưa nóng
lạnh đang có người ta đã có sẵn dữ liệu
rồi người ta có 1.000 sinh viên ở trong
Excel chẳng lại người ta làm quản lý
bằng lái xe giả sử thế sau đó thì người
ta
khi người ta kiểu người ta sẽ có cái xem
nó là như thế này để tôi thử thử đến mua
nhé
à à
còn chấm tiếp nữa thì trầm tiếp và nhóm
kia ở thì thì gần như là mình cứ tiếp
tục chấm do ngồi ngó mà cần chữa thì
mình chữa thôi còn không thì tí do lại
chấm tiếp các nhóm sau
sinh viên rồi thường nên có mã ở trường
nào chẳng có mã sinh viên bị sẽ có
cài đặt cho chuẩn đi Ai đi nêm này số
Giả sử có lớp đi sự có lớp class
class cũng nhớ class đi ok nhá ở đâu Tôi
đặt tên lớp của mình trong databases là
boss ngay cả lại ở sửa ngay à ở đây tôi
đang không có không lạnh chỉ tạm này
thôi Nếu mà muộn mấy ông muốn thêm ngành
ra vẫn thể làm được sao
em thật sự đây là ngành thì sẽ làm micro
sự thế
này
chấm lấy thật vừa rồi khám bệnh tuần này
sẽ bận nữa
xem hàng mình sẽ tự động sinh ra khi mà
bị điên này hay phết
cho nên này là sự Long này không ạ ừ ừ
em không có không tôi chỉ cho mấy ông ấy
thấy khái niệm khá hay này Nó là một cái
lu mà nó càng căng gì
chỉ cần
sex
data căng
xe đua
a móc Karu Đúng rồi móc Peru đã lẽ
ông xã lên
sẽ là có
mấy giờ này à
ở đây là person
u2a
nên Đây là
for you Good For You
ờ ờ
ở lớp lớp để lên cậu vẫn có sự đặc biệt
lại cho nó không bán được mình sẽ
sự sẽ có khóa như này từ khóa tạo lớp
từ khóa sẽ là sửa mình sẽ đã giả lập
trình với không được Trinh không sẽ mua
lần chua Phone này mình sẽ sẽ có cái bài
toán à
kíp là
I phone ren
đèn đây sẽ à lập trình này
a&e thì sẽ là quản trị em ạ Em
ý anh chả được
ở đó cho muốn nghe mình đi ra CP
cho mày không xem nha review rồi
ở đó lập trình Quản Trị lập trình quản
trị mã tự động tăng à mã mã nghị luận
soạn văn bản tự động tăng mã sinh viên
mình big in rồi ra đang tự động tăng
thừa hơi sai vì như trường mình sẽ mã
kiểu kiểu kiểu ngay cơ
Ừ Ok chưa
Ừ cái này giống kiểu pic ơi nhưng mà cái
này là ông có thể tạo sự điều đảo trông
Download report và
xôi đỏ nó còn có thể cậu nó còn xịn hơn
là điểm như này đâu một tại bàn đúng
không em Khỏe không
bạn ở tiệm bảng từ đơn đúng không ạ cô
gái bao gồm cả tao bạn khó này nilông
video nhé Nó sẽ ra câu in search này chị
nào
i i
copac Square cho ông ấy một nhìn thẳng
một lúc anh nha
chưa
ạ Bây giờ mình có mẹ mình sẽ nhảy sang
cái
thì
bộ phim sẽ nhảy sang cái Avira router đ
vì bà ghét này là import này
Đặt tên em có inbox đi ở
nhà bạn
Chỉ
cần em nó nó làm gì cả
Ai như này
à à
chị sẽ có một cái topic Tăng trưởng ở
đây
A
và inbox nó chết nó sẽ get ơn người đúng
cái view thì mày post thế thôi
này sẽ review này sẽ có một cái file
import cho.pe một cái phone này
một cái phốt à
à hay là
A và nêm cũng là file luôn đi Tân
sẽ là cậu ok rồi được chồng quá trọng
mình sẽ có chân mình sẽ nhảy đến một cái
router
ở mô tơ của mình đương nhiên là Lô Tô về
hết mấy ngày điện nha hợp âm Mình sẽ
post ở đây này không anh post này nên mà
nó là post ngay đây tôi sẽ nhập cái ô tô
này
tôi sẽ lô tô
mới thoát Thế sáng nay mấy support rồi
Everest chuẩn luôn classic có ý chuẩn
này
csrf này đó như này mình sẽ có được rồi
Cái này thì sẽ là post đi post lại và sử
thế ho gà thường mình đặt tên là phố sơ
sinh inbox được
dịch vụ xe tin body
sẽ đặt tên như này
à à bên này mình sẽ lấy
Ừ anh em mình sẽ lấy à
kết quả xổ lấy cái file đúng không phải
ở đây
cách lên đồ được
ờ ờ
thì mình lấy pha lại đây sao mình sẽ
import vào trong mình sẽ dùng cái lens à
dùng là excel excel Để mình post thì tôi
sẽ tôi sẽ
I install nó đã
à à xem nha
Ê pete thử ngay chạy thử luôn nhỉ ở pháp
này à
có
phải Sẽ Về Minh ấn OK thì mình bản chất
là mình chữ nhảy sang bên này rồi ông ạ
gợi ý gì này
thí sinh nhật
Ừ thôi đừng lừa nữa
khi bóp vào thì mình đưa như mình sẽ
em lấy từng hàng một soi import Amada
như thế này
a a khóc Tôi sẽ dùng lấy tất cả cùng một
lúc thì tôi sẽ dùng thì cậu là
thằng này thì ra nó đang bị Hơi bị rò
một điều mà nó không có cái Hằng nó
không gợi ý cái tor giây Nhưng mà thực
tế tôi sẽ giúp tôi sống lại thu Collagen
này Hãy Đợi tí sẽ chị
A Gọi chuyện rồi ok đấy sau đó Bây giờ
tôi sẽ AK à
à à mic nhóm ngoại inbox mà mình là tên
nó sẽ là Tư Đình II
Ừ cái này không biết à
Nên hình chữ S sport ngay
trong này đúng thôi Dùng chấp Ad xin
Made
a student I a sport nó
cho anh mấy inbox phải đúng
[âm nhạc]
nó rồi đây này đưa mình đã có cái file
này không ạ
ở bài này mình sẽ là tự đình con
khi chọn mình là đây mình sẽ là mình tu
cua Dai nha rồi à
A và đây sẽ là out ngay
chị
sẽ là Android hay thôi trợ
Ừ đấy tiếp theo tiếp theo là mình sẽ
truyền dữ liệu vào trong hàng này ạ hiện
chuyển file ở trong hàng ngày thì mình
xử lý cách xử lý ở đây nó sẽ là kiểu đơn
giản này
ý là sport kiểu nhà hai song
đổi lại thành thế này
a boss
thế này Đấy mai mình chuyển lên sẽ
chuyện ra bạn ạ vi Quét họ đến file là
xong
Ừ hình như à
sinh thì như thằng này tôi inbox sai thì
xóa đi như nó là thằng khỏe Thằng này
ngày mới đúng đó đó đó ok rồi rồi đấy
tôi sẽ thử đê đây cho mình xem nhé á
ở tại sao
Ừ ok chưa
nhưng mà đây là trong trường hợp là ông
chỉ có một ít và tối khuya là mấy ông ấy
inbox nên theo từng xí một còn nếu mà
ông inbox yêu kiểu là download ngay ông
import cả nó về chứ không phải là cụ thể
là từng sheet như này là sự tôi tận 2
xít trưởng Sinbad tôi đó là về
cậu ngay khi nó sẽ bao gồm nhiều sheet
để tôi thử Ví dụ như cũng xem nhé sẽ bao
gồm nhiều khi đã cho một sự thật này
đây là cái thằng xít đầu tiên đây không
ship là ai được ạ Đấy sẽ khác với nhiều
nhé nghe Tôi đang làm gợi ý cho mấy ông
về một ít thì nó sẽ như này thôi ok chưa
ấy thì với Hoài Hưng Yên à mình sẽ bỏ
qua thằng đầu là mình sẽ thêm cái was
heading ở đây sẽ là Quýt heading Grow
Tôi nhớ thì tôi ghi được ngay nếu không
nhớ thì
Anh Phi Nhung Bác tài liệu tài liệu có
hết pin đây này Đấy tiếp theo là
ạ bây giờ à
ạ bây giờ sự là D thằng e lại phát nữa
này nếu không sẽ thấy nó thay đổi sẽ
không còn kiểu không là cột đầu tiên nữa
cũng sẽ thành như này à
sẽ Ép kiểu thằng Thành Collagen Tôi
không thích thế thích kiểu dùng allez
allez cho nó nó khuôn nhỏ nhẹ hơn và
nhanh hơn nó Không tôi không quan trọng
là việc phải biến nó thành có di truyền
làm gì cả
a&p các bạn sử dụng thôi tôi có lịch sử
coi hay nếu không thích làm việc với đối
tượng được không sao
Ở đây bây giờ mình có dữ liệu như này
nhưng ở đây mấy ông thấy cũng bị một cái
đó là
anh ở đây Bài toán tình huống ở đây xảy
ra nha đây mấy ông già xưởng mà không
thấy có rất nhiều bạn vào ngành Quản trị
cũng như cũng rất nhiều bạn ở Lập trình
đó ông ạ Nhưng giả sử cái này cái này
tôi đang làm nó theo là kiểu là là là sự
tôi có 1.000 sinh viên này chưa phân lớp
chưa phân lớp nhé nghĩa phân lớp rồi thì
nó rất là dễ hấp Lớp mình chỉ được có
thêm vào trong cái lớp đấy Hoa mình tạm
lớp mới nếu không hiểu lý do ông ạ
Bây giờ tôi sẽ làm giải quyết luôn Giả
sử hai trường hợp đi một trường hợp mà
mà mà chưa
để giải quyết luôn cả trường hợp là thật
sự là
à à
Em gọi đi làm nữa à
ạ Bây giờ sửa tối tạo
có hiển thị ra các lớp ở đây rồi mình sẽ
chuyển dạ mình sẽ tạo lớp theo đúng lớp
đấy nếu có thôi Tôi để giải quyết trường
hợp để trước đi giờ tôi đặt tên là sự
mấy giờ này tôi cứt thích thì tôi cứ để
để nó là đây
Ừ tôi có kiểu như này thì cái cái này
với anh lớp lập trình một lớp quản trị
không ạ và xử thế xử thế
ở thị xã như này
Em chọn cho nó không diễn tả lại trở lại
Lý Hải
Ừ tôi có lớp lập trình mà lớp quản trị
không ạ đúng chứ sao bây ở tôi sẽ Giả sử
tôi xuất tất cả các sinh viên này vào
đầu tiên tôi sẽ phải lấy theo các lốp để
mình xuất vào nó sẽ như thế này
toán lớp mình luôn phải tạ lớp trước nó
mới mấy in xuất sinh viên Mà lớp đấy
đúng hạn thì đây mình sẽ làm là phối ở
đây này
anh ở đây này lại tưởng thằng này mình
sẽ là
thì mình sẽ lấy Costa dai bằng
a cost
phát xactly đúng
the first I
à à
thế này
ừ à Nó gợi ý chuẩn luôn này nó như này
lớp nếu nếu mà
nếu mà chưa có cái lớp tên là lớp ta
quản trị lại tôi thấy xót tượng
em có mấy ông sẽ thấy à Sinh năm bao lớp
và tên là quản trị luôn rồi mai đi là 60
chứ ở bên lớp này sẽ được tạo luôn này
Đúng như là mày không thể tự tạo của bia
bởi vì à Thằng thằng Excel thằng leveluk
xe mày có hứa là hai ở điểm là nó sẽ sử
dụng transaction để làm điều này phải
chạy Xong Cài file này Thành công đã khi
nó mới in xuất đồng loạt vào trong
database Còn không thì nó sẽ robot ở sẽ
khôi phục lại dữ liệu có nhiều chưa có
gì xảy ra cả nên là mấy ông thấy là rõ
ràng là ai đi hay ở là sáu kính thực tế
là chưa anh xót xa trong bao vây bởi họ
đã robot nó sẽ hiểu nó khôi phục lại dữ
liệu cũ rồi đấy cả rất hay thì bây giờ
bị Có code rồi mình sẽ đoạn này đơn giản
thôi mình sẽ chỉ việc là isis danh sách
AD nào nếu có nếu mà khóc ra là thế em
giả sử là ở đây mà không thấy có bị thêm
một nhược điểm đó là
A B C X ở đây không xem nha à
add ID của sinh viên này nó Nó là một
ẩm thực tế thực tế thì tội ít làm cái vụ
là kiểu à
Ừ nếu mà sinh viên trùng ai đi như này
thì một là tôi bỏ qua hay tôi sẽ update
mấy ông tùy tùy mày ông thích xử lý do
nào tôi tôi sẽ bỏ qua nhiều người sẽ chở
update lại theo cái ID là gì Cập nhật
lại nêm Cập nhật lại cả lớp học thật sự
thế là sự thế và cập nhật rất nhiều cái
khác thông tin cái này là chị đang là
thông tin về môi chỉ có 3 cột này thôi
còn thông tin thật thì nó sẽ có nhiều
cột hơn nó không ạ sẽ có thể như có hơn
và cũng cập nhật theo và thông tin đã
được Giả sử nếu mà ông muốn làm cái cập
nhật thì sẽ chỉ đơn giản là chị sẽ có tư
đơn như thế này
em update to read đ
Ý là mình sẽ là cập nhật theo của ID
ngay có xài đi này tiếp theo là mình
tôi có những cái ví dụ làm nên mình sẽ
cho nên này vợ có
Có ai đi
từ đó đến nay đi em ạ
khi gà cái này kiểu này được bởi vì
thằng này có thể biến thành mạng rồi nó
xa mẹ con ếch chiên này rất hay là nó
vừa là đối tượng mà vừa thấy là Mạc
không gọi còn lại được nhưng tôi thích
gọi cái này cho hiểu cho nào tượng này
đây cái em nó thích vào sẽ bị bầu báo
tưởng anh kệ nhé
D3 Giả sử tôi nếu mà tôi chạy đồng loạt
cái này thì tôi đã yên sốt sinh viên vào
và Insert luôn cả
khóa của cả lớp nếu nếu mà không tìm
thấy đây tôi sẽ thử nhé á
tích cực
chị thơ Gà một lời ông tạo khi nuôi bồ
nhưng mà có thể ông tạo gas cũng được
tùy tôi tạo đoạn này tạo gác cũng được
anh ơi
Ừ
cái này rất là sao như tôi từng giải
thích nó đã kiểu một là phia bồ để ông
hiểu là ông phải lấp và những cuộc gì
còn quát thì sẽ hiểu là kiểu những còn
gì ông không được điền vào còn không là
mặc định được điền vào hết là xử thế cho
bạn ấy thứ đó không có cột là nghị cảm
nên tôi thể hiểu cho Điền hết hoa ông sẽ
chỉ không cho điền của Tuyết tấn đâu
chẳng hạn Vân Tuy
thường ấy để chống cờ ai thì cứ sau
thích thì liên vào sẽ không bao giờ bị
không Khi mà con mít lên thì sẽ hiểu là
thêm cổ nào thêm của tao nó không bị xóa
Cô đào đi
Anh chạy đi chạy
sinh viên và cập nhật lại Cập nhật lại à
Ừ cái có sai đi không ạ Toàn bộ lại 90
90 hết những thế bạn có hai lớp này
nhưng Tuy rằng này ông thấy rất là nhanh
như thế này có mỗi hai giây thôi nhưng
thực tế đoạn này tôi không thích cánh
cái này đóng bài toàn nó bị chưa Tối yêu
ở điểm này đó là mấy ông thấy ra có cứ
có bao nhiêu sinh viên nó lại phải lấy
lại bấy nhiêu lớp để kiểm tra đóng vọng
thay vì này tôi sẽ có một cái nó khái
niệm mà tôi sẽ tạo một cái là ai có sờ
Đây à à Dạ Tôi sẽ tạo một mạng thế này
rồi tôi sẽ làm như thế này giúp thử xem
nhé Nó sẽ là ít đầu tiên kiểm tra nếu mà
kẻ Lacoste tại
anh nghe nhạc là tên đốc này
cho tôi kiểm tra nếu mà kệ đây Tại cái
cái
anh cái mã lớp tên lớp này chấm chấm chỉ
ra tên lớp phải sống thì tôi sẽ cho
thằng này
bằng luôn thằng này
em hỏi như này thế là xong à Ừ thế xong
rồi đấy Đấy
ông có thể lấy ra đây lấy ai đi được đấy
ông chưa muốn lấy cột ID rồi nha thôi
thằng ở dưới này thì tôi sẽ chỉ được
size nó là như thế này
nếu tôi sẽ đổi lại Nga sẽ xóa toàn bộ
sinh viên đi à
anh xóa sinh viên trong Thằng Hải đít
này nó rất là lâu vì nó sẽ xóa lần lượt
như này
Ừ
tôi tạm xóa hết điểm danh cũi nhé
treo luôn đấy
ở đây tôi thử chạy lại mày không thấy
xem tối ưu hơn bao nhiêu nhé
em vẫn sẽ kết quả như cũ nhưng tối ưu
hơn rất nhiều vì sao Bởi vì đợt này mình
sẽ chỉ kiểm tra là nếu mà mình chưa từng
truy vấn mình chưa từng truy vấn cài lớp
đấy thì mình mới truy vấn Còn mấy Nếu mà
lấy Chị vẫn ra rồi thì mình chỉ lấy ra
từ mạng thôi thì sẽ không không phải mất
công thêm tư vấn và không phải mất công
Đấy không phải mất công thêm truy vấn
vậy Và thậm chí ít ra có thể hơn nữa ông
ạ và sự rất là nhanh đấy ok chưa Nhưng
đây mới chỉ là làm theo kiểu dạng mà
Ê mày toán đơn giản là kiểu
instr có sẵn nhanh hết danh sách lớp Thế
bây giờ sự là bộ phận marketing gửi cho
bộ phận cos gửi cho ông 1000 1000 sinh
viên đăng ký nhập học là ngành Quản trị
và ngành lập trình rồi yêu cầu ông phải
phân lớp tự động giờ sự là mà ông Quý
gốc Giả sử gia sự nhá là là mỗi lớp 30
sinh viên ạ Đây lại thì ông sẽ làm kiểu
như thế nào bài toán sẽ tạo ra như thế
ngoại cho ví dụ Giả sử là bây giờ 1.000
sinh viên được cả hơn nhiều nhưng mà đáy
Ví dụ như thế thì sẽ làm như nào thì cho
tôi sẽ sự trở lại cho mày ông làm theo
cách Thứ Hai nha
ở miệng méo hình dung phải toàn không
anh để ghi ra nhé
có ai 1.000 sinh viên
nhập học ngoại nghĩa chưa có lớp đúng
không ạ Đấy sẽ thuộc hai ngành
là lập trình và Quản trị đúng không ạ
thì phải tự động phân lớp cho các sinh
viên đó
làm không những là tôi làm tối ưu rồi
đoạn văn lớp này đâu còn làm cho cậu nó
còn à Đỡ thiệt là mấy ông à là mỗi lớp
sẽ cố Tôi sẽ đến mà giới tính cơ Tôi đếm
và giới tính của tôi sẽ phân bộ giới
tính sao cho nó còn đều trong các lớp
đều một cách tuyệt đối thì không thể
không ạ bởi vì giáo xứ có 55 bạn nữ làm
sao mà đều cho lần đấy lớp được nhưng mà
nói chung là cũng sẽ hỗ trợ phần nào đấy
Đều Tránh trường hợp mà một lớp toàn nữ
sau vui tất cả các còn lại không có chữ
nếu không hiểu Ê hồi đời tôi có làm mấy
cái vụ này nữa cơ
tôi còn làm cả vụ liên quan đến điểm nữa
Vân Thủy dao ấm áp
Ừ Thế mới cần phải mềm không ạ
Ê mày không được khi không bình luận nữa
đam mới ông xem có bình luận không biết
được là mày ông có
a market theo kịp công
ngày ngon
như sau
Ừ
Thì bài toán ở đây là là nếu không sẽ
thấy là bây giờ tôi rủ rê đây này
rõ ràng mà phải bị sửa rồi lại chán phải
lấy lại phá mới
bộ
phim này ông thấy rõ ràng là bây giờ
mình phải
chỉ cần như là mình sẽ phải chứ sao
Khi mà mình sẽ phải gặp tất cả sinh viên
quản trị vào vào một chỗ đã dọn xong rồi
Khi mà đủ lượng sinh viên là ba mươi
chẳng ạ mình tạo lớp mới thì cứ thấy tạ
năm mới thường nó sẽ hai cách để làm hai
Cách để làm một là ông chỉ cần một vòng
lặp thôi nhưng không phải dùng khá nhiều
mà không sẽ đầy vào trong mảng chỗ anh
sẽ Insert cả mà cái một cách đây hai ông
sẽ làm hai cậu đó ông cấp bạo thành
nhiều mà con trước đã rồi ông chạy vòng
lọc những cái màng con đây tôi Tôi thích
cái thứ nhất Tôi sẽ là một cách duy nhất
nó sẽ như sau sẽ đưa nha sẽ Cũng mệt mà
làm mát sinh viên này cho đừng nghe này
tuy nhiên mà rõ ràng Đây là mảnh sinh
viên nhưng ý tôi là tôi sang gặp bọn nó
theo ngành sẽ như sau ở đây sẽ còn mấy
rồi
nhàng và đầu ngọn ngành của mấy ông ngay
không ạ Tôi sẽ nhóm nó vào đúng kiểu nhà
một ngày thôi là mình sẽ nhóm tất cả
sinh viên ở trong cùng này như thế này
Giờ tôi sẽ thử thì DK sinh viên thì ông
sẽ thấy là giờ sẽ chia làm ngành lập
trình sẽ này bạn và ngành của quản trị
sẽ này em ạ ok chưa thì mọi thứ nó lại
dễ dàng hơn rồi đấy Sau đó thì mình sẽ
duyệt cái mảnh này mình sẽ có
ý nữa
vãi cả chưởng
kiểm tra
Ừ nếu chưa có thì tạo
ạ sau đó thì duyệt tất cả sinh viên
khi kiểm tra nếu chưa có thì tạo rồi
truyền đúng có sai đi vào buổi xin mãi
chẳng cần phải có thể nhờ thôi không
Chúng ta không làm Thế ở đấy chúng ta
tối ưu hơn ờ
bảo là bị lớp của tôi là sự bây giờ lớp
của tôi có có ngày người không ạ
ở xóm bộ sinh viên đi ăn nhé
anh đã quên không xóa cái này sao đâu ạ
hơn thay vì nó xóa rồi Where are they
were đi đúng 1.000 Văn nha à
Ừ chị nói thôi đừng gọi nữa ờ thì mình
sẽ làm ở đây đó là bản chất là là mình
sẽ phải
Ở đây có một cái ra hai đó là mình sẽ
phải à
Ừ cái mảnh
Ừ cái mảnh màng màng này
toán ở đây là tôi sẽ sinh tự động ra lớp
màu ngọn Tôi sẽ đặt tên lớp là lập trình
một xong rồi cho ngồi ngành lập trình
sau đó thì là 92 cũng nhàng cũng là này
lập trình sau đó cứ lập trình một này
lập trình rồi Insert 30 bạn ở trong lớp
đấy ạ họ lập trình hay xuống ngành lập
trình các thứ thứ khi nó sẽ là như thế
này nó sẽ như thế này
Em đừng có ý nữa
ạ bây giờ bản chất là kiểu gì mình sẽ
tạo lớp không có phốt thì cả mình sẽ
kiểu định sẽ tạo luôn thì sẽ nhà luôn
cho mình kiểu gì mình sẽ tạo luôn nhé
mình sẽ còn nêm nó sẽ là
ở đâu để sống
nhà tâm lý đã thông tin à
đã bây giờ này Bây giờ chị 1
ở
đây phải nhìn này đúng box
anh vẫn là siêu đình nha anh vẫn từng tư
đình nha à à à
Đây like này
tôi sẽ đẩy thằng này ba như cái như thế
này Mà tôi sẽ là
Ừ cái này vẫn là ý thức sinh viên nhé
nên thành ra nó sẽ là chuyện giản là nó
ê ê
Anh tên nó là gì
Ừ tôi đã nghĩ tên cho thằng này à
đá
banh từ điển cũng được được rằng à
à à
anh ở đây sẽ là
costs tạo ra
nêm của nó sẽ làm mấy giờ nối với index
à Cậu cậu này
Em
hãy tạo ra một lớp
ờ ờ
khu resort cái này hơi bị nhược điểm một
tí đó là
Ừ anh student
Chế Linh
a Blast
ai sẽ có xe đi Ok ok
Jack được tôi thử trong đứng xem nhé có
sờ Đây nha à
ừ ừ
a slide đúng rồi
cơ
sở lại à à
anh alo alo tôi sang trả
có
ai là đại ok à
à à
ở đó tôi nshop một lớp mối là tên là
quản trị mạng một đó sao để Insert vào
khi
IDM 13 này cho tôi sẽ in xuất từng bạn
sinh viên ở trong lớp 13 đấy rồi Tiếp
theo 30 bạn một 30 bạn 1 cho đến hết
nhìn nhé
ừ ừ
Hà Nội à
nhà tôi đơn tại nêm Đợi tí sử dụng D
tháng tuần này xem ra gì à
E52
Anh bận tí đấy đi ị Vì
sao này ra nắng hay nhỉ
đá banh hàng ngày
xảy ra với rồi tôi đình
cả ngày nó sẽ phải trả với mạng chứ nhỉ
à
khi Alice Nine I
Ừ đúng rồi à
ở đó là Lê Ngọc Bích
Ừ hình như này không đúng
ở
đây nhìn em đúng rồi Ừ
anh không được
à à
Ừ đợi tí thì Dạo này làm gì đó Sai sai
rồi à
Cho hỏi ai đây Bun
a cho tôi phải xem lại code tôi rồi tính
em tự mình đi Xem cốt bạn chị Minh
Nguyên xử Dạo này rồi
Ừ ừ đúng rồi anh đang bà hẹn rồi
em xem lại code của tôi
à à
ừ ừ
ê ê
đúng
khi đó ngôi
vì thế đây trang này tức là sao nghĩa là
là cái đầu tiên thì ông xe nào đây tôi
sẽ có mảnh danh sách này là 400 400 đúng
không Tôi muốn lấy cấp 30 cái ra làm bột
30 cái ra một màn đã thì tôi sẽ dùng
trang nha Thì đấy Đấy sau đó đi tôi sẽ
chuyển nào là tôi
à à
Tôi lấy ra được danh sách 30 bạn như này
thôi cập nhật 30 bạn vào trong lớp này
Sao lại 30 bạn thêm heo lại cập nhật vào
trong lớp thứ hai ngọn bởi Lớp này đang
tự động tăng cái Tại sao tuổi + + ở đây
vì trí nhớ mà bắt đầu từ không ạ Tôi sẽ
tổng cộng vào đây tăng lên một cái Cứ
cộng vào tăng 21 thì cứ thế
khi chia tay cậu ngày cho nó dễ đi không
nên tác động thẳng vào này sẽ Cậu ta
nghe một như này
truyền thuê bao thì kết quả nó sẽ như
thế này nó sẽ load hơi lâu một tí ở cũng
một phút bốn mấy giờ cũng anh không phải
lo lắm đó sinh nhà quản trị mạng 1 đến
quản trị mạng 17 này lập trình một cho
em lập trình 10 18 này mà anh xuất 1.000
sinh viên Ok chứ
ở đó đó hai cách thì xử lý khi mà kiểu
một là ông cậu có rảnh sẵn danh sách lớp
rồi ông Trịnh xuất vào mà Một là ông có
danh sách à
ngành mới lớp mới thì ông muốn ông muốn
tạo gần như ông chỉ đi suốt mới thì ông
sẽ Secret này không không có file đấy
thì cả ông sẽ lấy thứ ba mươi bạn một 30
bạn 1.000 sub và về chưa
à à
ừ ừ
thực ra nó tận ba vòng lạc lòng nhau
ngay hơi khó hiểu một tí rồi khói không
Tí nho cách giải quyết đấy nó sẽ thế
Ừ Ok chưa
I3 I5 không ạ
ê ê
cho tôi bây giờ tôi đang khẳng động của
khi ạ để buổi chấm thi quay để bữa sau
buổi mày bắt đầu tôi thấy nói và cả
giọng đấy ạ Ừ nếu mà mày Nhóm kia chưa
on chưa cần chữa anh chắc là tôi chắc là
tôi nghỉ để thứ năm chả tôi chưa ông ở
nhóm đấy thứ 5 và Thứ 7 sẽ chữa lần sau
nhé
23 thực hành động
chả buồn Hôm nay chắc hả chị tạm mới thế
mấy buổi sau tôi sẽ trả lời thêm cho mấy
ông về mấy cái vụ này nữa
em có nhiều cá nhiều cái thì là tôi nốt
lại để mà sửa đó
À thế à cô này không để được này chỉ cốt
để mồm với em thả thôi chứ bây giờ làm
hết ngon mấy ông copy hết thì tội chẳng
biết chấm gì không ạ
chữa thôi nhỏ để hôm sau nhé Để hôm sau
nhé nhớ nhất này Ok nhé
ê ê